it's emotional it's really so emotional
so much more than i would have imagined
if um i didn't imagine winning but i
didn't imagine how
emotional it would feel right so now we
will have questions from the general
press
so the first one is for rachel lindsay
from
extra rosamond congratulations
it's thank you rachel thank you it's um
i mean it's extraordinary it's
extraordinary to be all dressed up in a
hotel room
on your own and that's exactly what i
wanted
to tell you about
you look beautiful everyone's been
talking about your dress you got to give
me a breakdown of that dress in your
fashion because you look stunning
absolutely stunning
well you know i did have some more
sensible options and then i thought
this is a you know this is a an
outlying year that calls for outlying
options you know you
you've got to express what it feels like
you know
to be all dressed up with nowhere to go
and this dress just felt like
whatever happened i would have fun and i
would um
and i'd make i'd find something to laugh
about smiling about
i think it was that really and i'd you
know float down a
corridor in a deserted hotel and
and find something fun in that like
like a pink ghost
next question goes to matt donnelly from
variety
hey rosamond congratulations um
the viewership on this film has been
staggering
hi can you hear me yes awesome
yes i can the viewership on this film
has been staggering around the world and
i'm just curious
if you know at toronto when this was
acquired if anyone else had released it
do you think you would have this kind of
audience
um and i'm just also wondering what you
think about the parallels people have
drawn to gone girl
and your character there
you know what matt the um
the audience that this film has got over
opening weekend
has been the closest thing i've
experienced to
the appetite that surrounded gongo and
it's been
so exciting to hear people
pass memes back and forth quote lines
steal
shots from the film and post them all
over the internet and talk about it and
also obviously
the way that it's it's reawoken the
conversation about conservatorship you
know that we're obviously
we're obviously delivering a comedy
we're delivering something dark and
unsavory and delicious
but we are you know hopefully giving you
that something to indulge in and enjoy
and also something to get angry about
i think we've delivered two punches
written with this um and it's an
important conversation
but you know it's it's amazing that even
in um
these lock down times the way that the
audience has felt connected
uh through conversation has been about
as close as you could hope for
uh outside of a cinema it's been quite
extraordinary actually
um and the parallels with gone girl um
well in that respect as i mentioned
already that's been magnificent
maybe the connection is me um because i
think marla and amy are
are very different women um you know
mahler is a much sort of scrappier
street fighter she's just
dressed up and designed the clothing um
but i i i do see that what people
respond to is is that a pole
at that that of what they're actually
doing and yet
being so disinclined to switch off from
them because there's something so
compelling
about the ingenuity of their fans i
think i think that's the similarity and
it's um
and it's certainly probably what drew me
to both characters frankly
because you know when i'm appalled and
yet
equally amazed at the audacity
i lean in okay next question
goes to natasha
hi congratulations um
so my question actually i didn't hear
where you were from
i'm sorry i didn't hear which outlet oh
i'm from buzzfeed
oh buzzfeed great okay thanks um
yeah so my question um is that you've
become kind of a lesbian icon online
particularly on twitter for your role
and i'm wondering whether you've seen
this fan reaction
if you've seen the memes um and what you
think about it
i am honored by it i am i am delighted
by it i am
favoring every minute of it because i
mean goodness me it's
it's you know
to be accepted isn't that what we all
want
and if marla and fran have been accepted
in the public imagination then that is
just magnificent
and i'll tell you what aza gonzalez was
the first person to call me
when i right after i made my speech he
was the first one off the buzzer with
the facetime
my wife and um yeah we were just
i mean we got so close and we you know
what
what a wonderful thing it was and the
way people have accepted it and and the
fun that people are having with marla
and fran that's the other thing i mean
we made this movie yes of course it's
about a serious subject
but you know we're telling it in a
deliciously
unsavory way that yes we'll make you
delight in it
and get angry about it and that's kind
of like a
like a like a double punch
um so that's what we aim for it's
exciting
it's the closest thing it's the closest
thing to feeling the reaction of an
audience in the theater
actually and it's been quite incredible
okay next question goes to
andrew froome from this nation
uh hi first of all congratulations on
tonight
thank you i'm i mean
yeah good talk because i can't
um so i guess i wanted to get what was
your first reaction
when you read this script could you see
where it was going
and also how much fun was it to spar
with the great diane wiest
i did not know where the script was
going when i read it i just each page
had me thinking no
but she cut no but she she cut but she
is
but she's not no she's going to she's
you know
every page and i thought i this is just
fantastic material i mean the audacity
of this woman's plan
how deplorable it is and yet how so
utterly
watchable i mean i was completely
i mean i just thought this is the most
fantastic character i've read in ages
and then um
yes when jay blakeson told me that
dianne wiest had signed on to play
jennifer peterson i couldn't believe it
um diane
is so unexpected in the choices she
makes she
doesn't make it easy to take advantage
of her i can tell you that she doesn't
make easy prey because of course she's
not
um and she surprised me with every
single choice she made
and i mean there is this charming
smiling gorgeous woman that we know from
so many movies and now here she is with
this dark
this dark wonderful kind of undertone in
this picture and i
i loved it
you